I wonder if you remember sitting in your
maths lesson wishing you could ask the
teacher to just stop and go over
something again I think it's quite a
common experience it was for me
particularly a math class to feel that
everyone apart from you has grasped a
concept and it can be very hard to find
the courage to stick your hand up and
admit that it's sailed right over your
head
well imagine if you could hit pause on a
lesson or even rewind it well one man
who has taken to the Internet to help us
do just that is Eddie whoo he's co-head
of mathematics at Tobruk technology high
school he features on Australian story
tonight and tells the story of how his
woo Tube website has clocked up nearly 4
million views worldwide assuming this
you go good afternoon
Richard how you going to hear this all
starts with an attempt to help one
individual student it was back in 2012
and I was teaching student he was
diagnosed with cancer which is ground
shaking for anyone let alone a 16 year
old boy and so we knew he was going to
have upcoming weeks of absence and it's
hard to learn anything when you're
learning it bits and pieces but
mathematics especially it's a very
coherent subject every concept relies on
the other ones which is why a lot of
people they related me ah I understood
everything until I heard you really get
my timetables then it just all fell to
pieces well when they started putting
letters in there that's when I had
checked out in other words if you lack
one building block the whole wall
doesn't work absolutely and so I knew
this is going to be disastrous for this
student to try and piece everything
together with all of this absence coming
up for him so I took my phone I propped
it up on the table and I just hit record
I knew it wasn't amazing but you could
see the whiteboard you could hear my
voice as I explained and that was a way
for him just to keep up with us while he
wasn't at school that's where it began
other students took notice and it just
sort of grew from there okay so you put
it up on the neck you made it you might
as well put it up on the net so he can
access it easily and then what other
people started watching as well well at
that time I had quite a few students in
my class who were involved in
extracurricular activities they'd be off
on a cadet hike or they were
arranging some fundraiser for prefect
and they'd come back the next day they'd
say sir we missed two lessons in a row
is there any chance we could use those
videos as well and I thought what I'm
not going to say no and then from there
you know students in other classes in
the same school realized hey you know
what we've got our own teacher
explaining stuff which is great but
maybe if we just want another angle on
things we can use this as well we can
all sort of watch something again that's
the crucial kind of solutely I mean I
can't remember what I had for breakfast
two days ago let alone some complex
mathematical concept from two months ago
so I find that it's something that
students use particularly before exams I
mean every year in October before the
HSC start I see this huge spike in
traffic because everyone is trying to
wrap their heads around a huge number of
concepts okay a great title lo woo tube
I definitely can't take credit for it
myself kids are always the most creative
ones I had a student in my roll-call
class years ago way before I started
this and he said to me ho sir would it
be really funny if you started putting
videos on the internet you called it
rutube and of course as an adolescent
boy that's exactly the way he said it
then when I began it so really literally
couldn't think of a better name now it's
stuck yes now it's like and you describe
the process whereby it starts with one
student and then a handful and then the
whole school of course now it's
worldwide isn't it you've got people in
country New South Wales to begin with
but then other states and now other
countries one of the things about
mathematics is it genuinely is a
universal language I mean you know we
sort of take it for granted that a name
like Pythagoras which everyone learned
in year 7 and 8 in Australia is
something that we're all supposed to
know about but this was ancient Greece
that we're talking about and so much of
math is from France and Germany and
China and mathematics is a language that
can speak to everyone and the Ameren of
the world needs to know about all the
more these days now that there's science
technology engineering math those STEM
skills are so much on the agenda of
everyone's everyone's government leads
to is pouring money into you know making
sure our students can understand this so
I think that's part of why it's had
worldwide appeal we're talking to Eddie
were whose word tube mathematics lessons
are being watched around the world he's
featured on Australian story tonight
he's
co-head of massive a cherry book
technology high school we always good at
it yourself it's just obviously speak
about it with clarity definitely not it
was not my best subject of school
English in history were the things that
sort of clicked for me and I love this
story and I love narrative mathematics I
didn't mind it but it took me so much
work to wrap my head around those
concepts and I had a great colleague
once who told me it's not hard for you
to teach what it was hard for you to
learn because if you put that mental
effort into understanding something that
didn't come naturally you can convey
that struggle and give that empathy okay
so actually it's helpful that you didn't
take to it like a duck to water well I
find I've had teachers myself who
they've shown a concept up on the board
I particularly remember this at
University and if someone did have the
courage as you were pointing out before
to put up their hand if they don't get
it sir they're just sort of pause and
look at you how can you not get out but
it's so obvious
you know I this is phrase that
mathematicians love you know they say
you know the following result is trivial
and left is an exercise to the reader
and it's almost a way of saying well you
know what can't you understand this if
you can't you know go work that's not my
problem and I've I've never viewed that
as my experience because as a student
what I needed was for someone to say
okay well it doesn't click with you this
way let's try something else and so
that's what is is characterizing my
approach of course why do you think so
many kids have problems with mathematics
it
we know this on a national level we know
Australia's not doing so well anymore
in international rankings but I think
people have individual experiences of it
I mean I certainly did it was the one
subject I never really got I always
disliked going I felt inadequate to the
task it's a very common experience why
so many of us math phobic I think that
there's a lot of factors obviously they
contribute to this if I had to pick just
one to highlight I think that one of
mathematics strong points is sort of its
own Achilles heel so for example when
mathematicians have a problem to solve
one of the things we desire to do is to
design a method for solving that problem
that sort of automates a lot of the
process that you don't have to think so
hard about it we can put all of the
numbers that are partners problem
faded into one thing it out pops the
answer we call those formulas
our formulas are super useful they're so
valuable modern societies built on those
but the true you know power of a formula
makes it so that you actually don't need
to understand what on earth it's about
to use it and so many students have this
formulaic step-by-step okay when you do
this and then this and then this who
knows why you do any of that but you can
get the right answer at the end now a
lot of students learn mathematics as
that just disconnected concepts a bunch
of steps that you have to follow for who
knows why and if students are learning
mathematics like that alone then of
course they're not really connecting
with why is this important what what
does it mean once I've got that number
at the end and how does this concept
this skill this step for solve your
problem fit all together and that's
obviously going to lead to problems Oh
many of the famous book by is Neil about
education called Summerhill written I
guess in the 60s and he talks about this
moment where a kid who's troubled by
mathematics wants to build a ham radio
and so he goes to his math teacher his
science teacher and suddenly because he
needs these formulas to build the thing
he wants to build suddenly the whole
field is accessible to him he
understands everything straight away
this same kid who was baffled by it for
years
I mean feeling that need I think is
actually so crucial a lot of people and
I think it's entered into our you know
our vernacular to be able to say ah you
know if someone is unemotional then we
call them cold and calculating that's
the phrase that we have but I don't buy
that I think that mathematics is
intensely emotional which is why if you
get that personal connection to
something I want this I want to be able
to solve this problem then that's what
drives you and it's when children lack
that that's when they disengage hmm I've
got a friend who is a pure mathematician
and ie once was talking to me about some
problem you were solving and he said it
was a beautiful solution and I loved
that phrase it's actually more not topic
it's more an art subject than we think
it I think that there's a lack of
understanding of how creative
mathematics is as a field in fact
mathematicians are some of the most
creative people around because they
spend all day imagining things and
that's you know you're trying to wrap
your head around some
that no one has ever seen before it's an
abstract reality and so we you need to
conceive of a way to interact with that
in a way that allows you to solve the
problem and you need to think of
multiple ways to approach something when
it's not clear to begin with those are
all the hallmarks of a creative pursuit
and when people miss that about
mathematics they think of it as a very
you do this and then this and this
creativity is not involved that's when
they miss the true essence of the
subject we're talking to to Eddie will
imagine having him as your math teacher
well in the sense the whole world does
through his word chewed math Channel
I don't want more such it's bad shape
what's that chance me is that is that
very like again again something we
usually say to you batches right which
means actually here it's not very likely
which is very funny be close some of you
have noticed that flinches is rightly in
this area in fact ever happens this is
what English is like I feel I guess up
your badge to try and learn English
you're like do it slim chance and that
chance literally read exactly to safety
talk to us about your vocation how did
you end up a teacher and I know on
tonight's program some of your relatives
say our you know mum and dad expected
them to be a lawyer and lots of money
and do all these things but you didn't
for me when I was at school there was a
real sense of look we understand you
have a huge set of every every child in
school has a huge said abilities of
skills and passions and it's not easy to
find what it will be that marries them
all together in a way that serves a
community has meaning and purpose I was
very fortunate that when I was at school
I had number one teachers who I could
see were a worthwhile example to follow
they knew their stuff but they also knew
their students and care about them they
weren't the kind of you know I person
who's up the front of the classroom and
the second the bell goes they leave
because my job is just to explain things
to you I could see they really cared
about us and our growth as characters
not just our academic growth so seeing
that as where was the way where you
I I attended James's agricultural high
school I you know I've been a public
school boy my entire life and so I was
very fortunate to have that experience
mr. best my music teacher mr. Brown my
agriculture teacher stood out for him
particularly because I was never a star
in those subjects I wouldn't I was never
the the apple of their eye but it didn't
matter they cared about me as a student
regardless of whether I had a talent for
those subject or not so the first thing
was just seeing great teachers and
benefiting from their their work in
their professionalism but secondly I was
very fortunate that I got to be involved
in a lot of extracurricular activities I
think of Cadets prefect the Christian
group here support leading all of those
gave me a sense of how much joy I was
able to get out of seeing someone else
learn something and be able to help that
in that excel them in that experience I
just fell in love with it
you know seeing there's a moment when
someone catches this is what it's about
or I can do this I actually have this
ability I thought that was the if you
ask me three weeks ago if I could do
this I want it told you it was
impossible and I get to have that moment
day in day out you know the syllabus
that I teach has been the same for years
but every year I get new students and so
it's new all over it and that effort to
find a way through to that particular
students level of understanding here
we're with that we with Eddie where you
listen to ABC radio
Sydney did you get a bit of pushback
from your parents when you said I'm
going to be a teacher did someone point
out the salary level and all that occur
well my mom was particularly upset
because you know as a migrant coming to
this country so that I could be born
here I you know it wasn't to be just the
teacher because it's a very humble
profession you know it's not recognized
as something which deserves high status
which i think is is sad and so there was
yeah a disappointment for her because
they'd made this huge sacrifice and you
know what did you think was the point of
doing that and I think they were upset
that I took all this academic potential
that I had and went to something which
in their view at the time they didn't
think would be a good use
of that so it was challenging for him at
first I mean sadly my mother passed away
my first year of university so she
hasn't been able to see the successes
that I've been able to have and that I
love what I do you know every day I get
to come to work and I know that what I
do makes a difference because I can see
it on the faces of the students I get to
teach well your high status to us
anyway thank you so much for coming in
and talking to us look forward to
tonight's program Australian story
tonight 8:00 p.m. when you can really
meet Eddie Wu and hear the amazing story
and see some of the way he teaches on
the internet with his rutube mathematics
channel he listened to ABC radio Sydney